le frère de chercher ce coup s'est pendu
à vienne pas membre de la famille arrêté
le premier ministre fait très romane
s'explique explique sa politique
le syndrome roumain dans la politique
française le parti communiste secoué
georges marchais en direct dans ce jour
chez cos slovaquie buczek élu président
de l'assemblée fédérale
vaclav havel futur président de la
république dans ce journal aussi les
poupons en difficulté dans les mers
australes
il a lancé un appel de détresse il était
deuxième de la course autour du monde
bonsoir les malheurs de la famille
chaussée secours
le frère du dictateur s'est suicidé à
vienne pourtant on disait qu'il était
l'un des seuls à ne pas avoir profité du
régime
il était quasiment en exil à vienne le
même jour on a appris aussi que trois
autres membres de la famille avaient été
arrêtés à ce qu'en dit qu était la soeur
la belle soeur et le neveu
tout cela au moment où la tv roumaine
diffusé quelques images de l'intérieur
du palais présidentiel regardez bien
c'est la première fois que l'on pénètre
dans l'antre du génie ou peut-être de
l'ogre des carpates jean-marc il use une
caméra un peu ivres peut être de liberté
pour montrer je cite la télévision
roumaine la villa du camarade parlons le
palais du chef
enfin la maison du président de l'ex
président commentaires bien à l'image
d'une roumanie qui qu'idéologiquement
bafouille
oui c'est de ce bureau que partaient les
ordres terrible du tyran
et les habitants de bucarest pour
découvrir un étrange décor bronze du 19e
tableaux de maîtres pied de lampe kitsch
et argenterie clinquante de petits
bourgeois ici des robinets en or de
rigueur dans la salle de bain de l'ex
apprenti cordonnier devenu dictateur
retour au siège de la télévision
roumaine plus de francs-tireurs cette
fois ci mais des soldats qui creusent
quand même de nouveaux trous individuels
on ne sait jamais
à l'intérieur le soldat de garde est
bien plus optimiste il a sur les genoux
un cause onac gâteaux traditionnels de
fait un gâteau qui aujourd'hui parle lui
aussi de démocratie et de liberté cet
après midi à 17h heure de bucarest qui
expirait l'ultimatum des nouvelles
autorités les membres de la police
secrète la tristement célèbre ses cours
itable devait se rendre et déposer leurs
armes alors tout de suite nous allons
aller à bucarest retrouvez en direct
notre envoyé spécial stéphane magnier
stéphane bonsoir alors est-ce que
l'ultimatum tremble respecter est ce que
les hommes de la securitate se sont
rendus mais que tu vu le gouvernement il
ya encore une heure et demi à peine
effectivement il semble bien que le show
soit maintenant calme c'est à dire qu'on
ne redoute plus de tirs de francs
tireurs dans les rues alors la preuve la
preuve c'est que nous sommes là vous
voyez nous sommes dans les jardins
l'ambassade
il y à 24 heures cela aurait été
impossible à faire d'abord parce que les
gens qui sont éclairés dans un jardin
aurait servi de cible parfaite pour des
francs tireurs
or ce soir on peut le faire en toute
sécurité par sas est une preuve
aujourd'hui la situation se stabilise et
revêt alors stéphane on l'a dit vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
rencontré le gouvernement ce
gouvernement ce nouveau pouvoir il siège
à peu près sans discontinuer travaille
beaucoup il ya beaucoup à faire
oui il a beaucoup à faire il a beaucoup
travaillé il a eu encore une session
aujourd'hui et puis ses membres se sont
un peu dispersés pour travailler chacun
dans leur secteur
je crois surtout qu'il faut bien
comprendre que c'est une révolution
spontanée alors que dans tous les autres
pays
on a eu des groupes politiques ont
travaillé pendant des années pour
préparer la presse télé nice - en tout
cas la presse brédji prévenez wismes si
on peut s'exprimer rassis là pas du tout
ce sont des gens qui aujourd'hui sont au
gouvernement et qui ne se connaissaient
pas il y a dix jours à peine
donc c'est pour vous dire à quel point
ces phrases il à quel point aujourd'hui
la moindre contestation la moindre
suspicion à leur égard est une suspicion
qui peut porter et pour vous dire aussi
qu'ils sont obligés de s'appuyer
complètement sur les sur les
les officiels ce qui était déjà en place
à l'époque de ceausescu
les techniciens si vous voulez alors
j'ai rencontré le premier ministre
il y a donc deux heures à peine écouté
ce qu'il nie 12e nous avons réussi à
obtenir le plan complet des combes des
sous sols de ce palais nous avions été
informés dès le début que le palais
était minée par keolis coup et qu' il y
avait en mécanisme disons de déclencher
l'explosion qui pouvait nous échapper et
que nous étions à tout moment dans un
grand danger
donc l'armée était là pour déblayer pour
vérifier tous
mais comme toujours l'armée elle a reçu
des ordres elle veut les appliquer les
étudiants ils venaient discuter
ils voulaient dialoguer chaque invétéré
selon ces révolutions donc pour vous
c'est un faux problème il n'y a pas deux
il ne risque pas d'y avoir de nos
positions
cette révolution ce mouvement
révolutionnaire a été l'oeuvre des
jeunes j étais par mieux géré à 80% des
jeunes abiker et je veux dire c'est à
dire dans la nuit du vin du 21-22
ensuite dans la matinée du 22 et surtout
l'après-midi du 22 au moins 80 % étaient
des jeunes et jeunes jusqu'à l'âge de 25
ans il y avait aucune organisation de ce
qui c'était ça a été produit c'est un
mouvement spontané
donc c'est leur révolution
j étais moi est vraiment croyez moi je
sais pas comment je suis arrivé à parler
à la tribune
j'ai été poussé et j'ai été poussé pense
que quelqu'un m'a dit c'est un beauf
d'université je le connaisse un prof
d'université et j'ai été poussé pour
arriver à peine changé ce prix était à
il y avait dix minutes qu'il était parti
ou un quart d'heure avec son hélicoptère
et je suis arrivé à la tribune
alors ce que je veux déclarer maintenant
c'est que le jour où ce mouvement sera
récupérée par une force politique ou par
quelqu'un moi j'y suis plus c'est clair
effectivement c'est pas facile de tout
régler tout de suite et stéphane dans
vos reportages notamment à 13h
aujourd'hui j'avais l'impression que la
population avait conscience de cette
difficulté parce que souvent la
population roumaine pas dans vos
reportages paraissait inquiète
oui c'est vrai c'est ce que je vous ai
expliqué il ya encore quelques instants
aussi c'est très fragile pour l'instant
c'est vrai c'est la révolution c'est la
liberté tout le monde croit que enfin
ils vont pouvoir respirer s'exprime fait
des choses qui étaient impensables
affaire il ya encore dix jours
mais quand même il y a le doute il y à 7
et un couvent table angoisse qu'ils ont
subis pendant 25 ans tu vraiment
comprendre ce que ça signifie jusqu'à
quel point les gens étaient mal à l'aise
était sous pression permanente chez eux
et bien je vous propose d'écouter ce
reportage terrible car françoise joly
dans un orphelinat
c'est là où était élevé les enfants qui
devaient être pris dans chaque famille
vous m'entendez bien qu'ils devaient
être pris dans chaque famille écoutez le
reportage de profession orphelinat
numéro 1 de bucarest le plus grand
d'europe du sud-est 718 bébés de 0 à 3
ans vivent dans ces bâtiments
ce sont les enfants du décret 770 de
chaouch et secoue un décret de 1966 qui
interdisait toute contraception tout
avortement une politique nataliste
effréné avec obligation pour les femmes
de subir un contrôle gynécologique tous
les trois mois avec obligation pour les
médecins de convaincre ces femmes de
mettre cinq enfants au monde
sur ses cinq enfants seules trois
restaient dans les familles les autres
sont ici enfants de chaouch et ce coup
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient destinés à
l'état destinés à la securitate et ou
aux unités d'élite passé l'âge de 3 ans
et enfants se retrouvent ici dans
l'orphelinat numéro de 3 à quelques
centaines de mètres du premier dans cet
établissement
nous apprendrons aussi qualité la
destination de certains d'entre eux ces
enfants étaient très bien soignés car
beaucoup partent à l'étranger pour être
adoptées contre une forte somme d'argent
des taxes il représentait un intérêt
matériel pour l'état de chaouch escaut
des tattes de femmes il a trente mille
francs c'est à ce prix que chaouchi
secousse aider ces enfants à l'étranger
en france en italie en belgique ou en
israël
l'autorisation d'adoption était donné
par chaouchi secours lui même qui signe
de sa propre main tous les documents
voilà je crois de faire le moindre
commentaire après après ce reportage
nous retrouverons stéphane bien sûr dans
nos prochaines éditions
merci merci à vous et à tous nos envoyés
spéciaux quelques mots sur l'aide à la
roumanie et la flûte ou côté mais il
faut continuer car les besoins sont
immenses toutes les informations qui
vous sont utiles pour aider ce pays et
bien vous pouvez les obtenir sur le
minitel 36 15 codes à deux vous saurez
ainsi comment et à qui donner lui les
secours par la voix de son directeur
général federico mayor s'est dit prête à
collaborer aux efforts de redressement
de la romaine est effectivement un des
grands problèmes qui se posent c'est de
remettre la roumanie sur les rails faire
repartir son économie et ce ne sera pas
simple pas seulement à cause des grands
événements de cette semaine la roumanie
était déjà une économie quasiment
ruinées obligé de tout vendre à ses
voisins 70% de sa production agricole
partait vers l'union soviétique
gérard leclerc toujours des files
d'attentes aux portes des magasins de
bucarest
mais enfin pour quelque chose le
changement de régime a mis fin aux
années de rationnement organisé par
ceausescu au nom d'un pseudo programme
d'alimentation scientifique pas plus de
300 grammes de pain par jour et 1 kg de
viande par mois la campagne roumaine est
pourtant l'une des plus fertiles
d'europe mais elle a été ruiné par une
collectivisation systématique 400 fermes
d'état exploite 90 % des terres avec une
productivité dix fois inférieure à celle
de l'agriculture française
plus d'un millier de villages ont été
rasés et
remplacé par des centres
agro-industriels et puis 70% de la
production agricole est exporté vers
l'urss dont la roumanie est devenue le
premier fournisseur en viande et le
troisième en fruits l'industrie roumaine
n'est guère plus vaillant et la roumanie
possède pourtant un sous sol riche en
pétrole et en minerais mais alors qu'est
l'ex gloire qu'elle exportait des
hydrocarbures dans les années 70 fautes
d'exploration de nouveaux gisements
elle doit en importer aujourd'hui est
imposé à sa population une pénurie cruel
de chauffage et d'essence
les grands centres sidérurgique ou
chimique fierté du régime manque de
matières premières et son dépassé
technologiquement usines citroën de
craiova qui devait sortir 150 mille axel
parents n'en produit que 20000
inexportable à l'ouest car de mauvaise
qualité
seul point positif en dix ans et au prix
de souffrances
la roumanie a remboursé ses dettes 11
milliards de dollars contractés
notamment pour la construction de
travaux pharaoniques autoroute ou palais
présidentiel de bucarest à paris
aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont rendu hommage à notre
confrère jean-louis caldéron de l'a5
il est mort à bucarest en faisant son
travail de journaliste il avait été l'un
des premiers à arriver sur place dans la
petite église beaucoup de roumains elle
de paris et aussi de nombreux confrères
le syndrome roumain dans la politique
française chacun se défend d'avoir eu
des relations à un moment ou un autre
avec monsieur chat ou ses scoops à
droite comme à gauche les plus attaquées
dans cette affaire ce sont georges
marchais et la direction du parti
communiste de l'extérieur bien sûr mais
aussi de l'intérieur du parti beaucoup
de communistes critiquent leurs
dirigeants alors georges marchais vous
êtes en direct avec nous à marseille
bonsoir monsieur marché alors monsieur
marché je vais vous poser la question
que je crois tous les français se posent
est-ce que lorsque vous voyez les images
de la roumanie comme nous tous est ce
que vous regrettez d'avoir jusqu'en 84
passer vos vacances en roumanie que ce
que je regrette c'est de ne pas avoir eu
une connaissance suffisante de l'ampleur
de la catastrophe que connaît
aujourd'hui la roumanie ça je le
regrette mais vous ne saviez pas je
savais je vous fait observer que la
dernière fois que je suis allé en
roumanie ce temps 1984 et je n'y suis
jamais retourné depuis
et nous avons critiqué souvent à
plusieurs reprises souvent le fait que
la roumanie connaissait régime
profondément antidémocratique et
deuxièmement et vous venez de
l'expliquer tout à l'heure quand raison
d'une politique uniquement orientée vers
l'exportation des conditions de vie de
la population était extrêmement
difficile mais vous saviez s'appliquant
monsieur marché comment vous saviez tout
ça piquant mais nous ça nous savons ça
depuis pas mal de temps je vous fait
observer que cela fait de près de 15 ans
que l'on a commencé une critique
sérieuse du socialisme en existe un à la
fois sur le plan économique sociale et
démocratique et que par conséquent la
roumanie étaient concernés comme
d'autres pays socialistes et donc vous
regrettez tout de même d'avoir été passé
il y passer vos vacances jusqu'en 84 je
regrette je regrette qu'elle voulait
effectivement je m'aperçois qu'il ya une
une campagne assez déshonorante pour
ceux qui en sont les auteurs en
définitive parce que bah oui je suis
allé en vacances chez écouter en tout et
pour tout je suis allé quatre fois en
roumanie et j'ai fait de compte j'ai dû
discuter 12 heures avec coc ce coup je
ne les ai jamais rencontrés ailleurs
qu'au comité central ou dans une maison
qu'il avait au bord de la mer mais nous
n'avons jamais eu d'autres rapports
jamais d'autres rapports que des
rapports de caractère politique
c'est-à-dire de discussion de parti à
parti sans rien faire même chez monsieur
marché vous ne saviez pas tout sur la
roumanie
mais ce que vous aviez réellement
cherché à savoir oui oui je pense
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue avoir fait
beaucoup plus d'efforts que la fed
ambassadeur de france parce que la
constatation qui s'impose c'est que
jamais le gouvernement français aussi
bien quand la droite est au pouvoir que
lorsque c'est le parti socialiste jamais
le gouvernement français n'a émis
officiellement la moindre protestation
contre ce qui se passait en roumanie
monsieur nord je vous fais observe
attendait oui je vous fais observer pour
ce qui me concerne j'ai ici un dossier
je ne m'en servirai pas si vous voulez
je vous fais parvenir mais de
remerciement de roumains pour toutes les
interventions que toutes ces dernières
années j'ai effectuées en leur faveur et
notamment j'ai une lettre qui met très
sensible c'est celle de la fille de
dorine à cornet a pour laquelle je suis
intervenu par conséquent quand je vois
aujourd'hui très honnêtement jamais je
n'aurais je savais que ce pays était un
pays où la démocratie socialiste n'avait
rien à voir avec la conception que nous
en avons monsieur je savais que si je
savais je savais que ce pays avait des
conditions de vie déplorables jamais je
dis bien jamais je n'aurais pensé
sinon oui je le dis très franchement non
seulement je n'y serais pas allé
mais j'aurais fait beaucoup plus encore
que nous n'avons fait pour condamner la
politique de ce bourreau du peuple
romain alors nous avions des
informations mais pas au niveau de ce
que nous découvrons aujourd'hui comme
vous vous nous avons nous nous vous
avons bien compris pardon monsieur
marché j'ai élargi sur un plan plus
général tout de même toutes les
démocraties populaires en quelques mois
rejette le communisme ça ne vous
aideront le pas mais ça me brûle pas
dans les convictions communistes
socialistes n'ont absolument pas
j'ose le dire ne va pas vous amener à
changer parce que le monde change vous
vous changez pas mais c'est vous qui ne
changeait pas c'est vous c'est les
médias qui ne changent pas mais moi je
change
moi je change je vous fait observer que
nous avons fait la critique de la
politique de notre parti pendant une
longue période où effectivement nous
avons soutenu d'une manière
inconditionnelle le modèle soviétique
mais depuis le 22e congrès en 1976
ça fait quand même maintenant 14 ans
n'est ce pas nous avons fait une
critique sévère de cette politique
oui nous n'avons rien à vendre et nous
n'avons jamais cessé et les
téléspectateurs doivent s'en souvenir
ils m'ont entendu en janvier dire
personne ne le disait à ce moment là que
le régime que le système en vigueur en
roumanie n'avait rien à voir avec le
socialisme qui marche et ce en une autre
version
aujourd'hui j'ai marché en tout état de
cause il n'est pas question pour vous
aujourd'hui de revenir sur la règle de
l'unanimité qui est en vigueur dans
votre parti qui montrent que ça change
pas beaucoup tout de même mais y'a pas
mais qu'elle règle de l'unanimité c'est
une invention pure et simple
c'est une invention des des idées
communistes novateur et écouter ce
qu'ils les gens les gens dont vous
parlez yabuki en parler il ne représente
strictement rien ça strictement rien
fait drôle d ailleurs jour qui ne
représente rien
les opposants n'ont alors écoutez il
faut savoir je suis venue du lieu où je
me repose je fais 80 kilomètres en
voiture pour vous répondre
et si vous ne me laissez pas parler il
fallait me laisser là où j'étais
vous savez ça fait déjà six minutes
monsieur marché comparé liant encore sur
la roue à la tchécoslovaque - posez moi
des questions cohérent les chevreaux
d'apple au caire oui à la première
nous avons condamné le régime en vigueur
en roumanie qui n'a rien à voir avec le
socialisme
et il est vrai que nous savions qu'il y
avait de très graves défauts mais un
régime aussi abominable que celui que
nous découvrons aujourd'hui
non nous ne savions pas et si nous
l'avions su nous aurons une fait
beaucoup plus les salles concernant
marcheurs l'a compris mais concernant
notre parti mais ya que vous vous parlez
bon j'attends poperen d'ahmed rigou etc
ce sont des gens qui ne représentent
strictement rien jamais l'église
monsieur marc ulmann et m'arrêter parce
que maintenant il faut parler des
tchécoslovaques si on compare les huit
minutes
non non tu m as may qui rejette le
communisme mais où les choses se passent
plutôt bien c'est la tchécoslovaquie
donc retournement symboliques de
l'histoire c'est alexander do check qui
a été élu tout à leur président de
l'assemblée fédérale tchécoslovaque
monsieur double check vous le voyez ici
la 68 après le printemps de prague en 68
monsieur dusek avait été écarté de la
scène politique et renvoyer dans sa
maison de campagne
il revient sur le devant de la scène
d'une manière spectaculaire et dimanche
en tchécoslovaquie c'est l'élection
présidentielle
c'est le parlement qui va choisir le
nouveau président du pays par une
procédure assez compliqué un seul
candidat qui sera très vraisemblablement
élu ceva cela avait l'écrivain
christophe martin et andré sort à le
rencontrer à prague
à la veille de l'élection présidentielle
vaclav havel est l'homme le solliciter
de tchécoslovaquie des ambassadeurs des
représentants des forces armées
et bien sûr les médias du monde entier
tous veulent rencontrer celui qui en
deux mois est passé de la dissidence aux
plus hautes sphères de l'état
je n'aurais pas posé ma candidature pour
être un président symbolique
j'ai accepté parce que mes amis et le
peuple sont convaincus qu'il y a
beaucoup de travail à faire je
mais si je suis élu c'est pour une
période assez courte
normalement dans six mois il y aura des
élections législatives en
tchécoslovaquie
les premières élections libres depuis 40
ans et c'est le nouveau parlement choisi
démocratiquement par les électeurs il
désignera le président pour cinq ans
donc je suis un président de transition
quelles raisons vous souhaiteriez mettre
en place somme on devoir principal sera
de conduire ce peuple aux élections
libres je peux par des voies honnête des
paisibles
bien sûr j'aurai d'autres obligations
bob celle de tout chef d'état
c'est mon rôle essentiel c'est bien la
mise en place de la démocratie dans
notre pays
non seulement il y a 6 mois si quelqu'un
et vous avez dit avant la fin de l'année
vous serez président de la république
est-ce que vous l'auriez cru bien sûr
que non je réponds c'est qu'il
plaisantait demain vaclav havel celui
qui depuis vingt ans se bat pour la
liberté la démocratie devrait devenir le
neuvième président de la république
alors l'auteur de pièces de théâtre sera
sur le devant de la scène pour une
nouvelle page d'histoire de la
tchécoslovaquie
en espagne deux gardes civils ont été
tués dans un attentat à girone dans les
asturies pas de revendication mais
l'attentât pourrait être l'oeuvre du
gras pour d'extrême gauche les banques
suisses vont débloquer les fonds des
dictateurs se ceausescu qui pourrait
revenir à l'état roumain mais aussi ceux
de noriega à la demande des américains
les autorités suisses ont été très
rapides à réagir sur ce sujet panama et
d'autres informations tout de suite
louis carzou les négociations sur le cas
du général noriega toujours dans
l'impasse les autorités vaticanes n'ont
toujours pas donné de réponse officielle
aux demandes américaines et panaméennes
cependant le nonce apostolique de panama
city aurait remis aujourd'hui aux
troupes américaines à document les
autorisant à intervenir dans la
nonciature en cas de prise d'otage fort
séisme ce matin sur la côte sud est de
l'australie 11 morts et 122 blessés
selon un bilan provisoire et la ville de
newcastle à centre industriel de 500000
habitants qui a été la plus touchée par
la secousse d'une intensité de 5 points
5 sur l'échelle de richter
cet après midi l'armée et la police ont
dû intervenir pour mettre fin aux
pillages
ludovic audouy témoin numéro un du
massacre de castelvieilh remis en
liberté par un juge madrilène
le jeune homme recherché depuis le 20
décembre dernier a été entendu toute la
journée en présence d'enquêteurs
français
mais le magistrat a jugé ces
déclarations trop incohérente pour
l'inculper dès son retour prévu demain
ludovic audouy devrait être de nouveau
entendu par les enquêteurs
atmosphère de fête à la bourse de paris
où la séance s'est de nouveau hp sur une
hausse de 0 66%
une fête qui n'est toujours pas du goût
de la devise américaine le dollar
continue de baisser à 5 francs 74 40 la
course autour du monde en solitaire un
pari incroyable partie à la mi novembre
des trappes d'olonne le début de la
course s'était passé à peu près bien
pour les solitaires la dizaine de
solitaire qui étaient partis mais
maintenant que les concurrents sont en
dessous des 40e rugissants sous
l'afrique du sud déjà les problèmes
commencent ainsi philippe poupon le
champion du monde qui était deuxième de
la course a lancé un appel de détresse
patrick 9 inquiétudes au pc de la course
autour du monde en solitaire
leur émission fut révision opérée depuis
14h45 heure française philippe poupon a
déclenché sa seconde balise de détresse
deuxième derrière titouan lamazou après
quatre semaines de course
philippe hugon fils est encore à plus de
12 noeuds cette nuit lors des derniers
relevés
deux heures plus tard vers 5h ce matin
les balises indiqué que son bateau avait
changé de cap et dérivait au large des
côtes d'afrique du sud en plein
quarantièmes rugissants
alors qu'est ce qui a pu arriver soit
une voie d'eau importante soit le bateau
a chaviré il a démâté soit apparemment
le fait qu'il ait déclenché lui même les
balises la balise argos en tout cas de
sécurité fait nous fait dire qu'il y ait
d'abord il a pu embarquer dans un canot
de survie mais il a donc il n'est pas
tombé à l'eau quoi depuis 18h le pc
pendent d'appeler les bateaux les plus
proches de la position de philippe ou
compromis à répondre jean luc band aid
mais le plus gros espoirs et loïck
peyron qui se trouve à 200 milles de
coucou
et on est en train pendant la vacation
actuelle d'essayer de contacter la dap
hoc qui est le plus proche lui pour
l'instant mais jusqu'à présent la pas
joint ce soir un avion a décollé
d'afrique du sud pour tenter de repérer
philippe poupon seul problème et de
taille une mer très formée avec des
vents soufflant à plus de 80 kilomètres
heure seul élément rassurant ou qu'on a
déclenché manuellement sa balise de
détresse
il serait donc toujours à bord soit de
son bateau soit de son canot de
sauvetage
les plus beaux exploits sportifs de
l'année c'est ce soir sur antenne 2 ils
seront récompensés c'est la
traditionnelle remise des trophées
d'antenne 2 présenté par gérard holtz et
christian qu'il est pour l'heure voici
en voici quelques-uns de ses exploits
dominique le glou nous met l'eau à la
bouche
sheffield l'image du drame pour
liverpool et son football 95 victimes
un trop plein d'amour liverpool une
semaine plus tard l'image de l'espoir
toute une ville fière solidaire unie
pour prier souhaitait plus jamais cela
plus jamais cela non plus un boxeur qui
meurent sur un ring david ciot rêvait de
devenir un champion il est mort à 22 ans
c'est le cinquième boxeur décédé en
france en 40 ans
métier à risques prise de risque pour
stéphane cosse herman qui se reçoit sur
le menton le corps craque
heureusement plus de peur que de mal
pour le champion de france de gym chaud
il a eu chaud dire abberger prisonnier
d'une voiture en feu mais inde m grâce à
la rapidité d'intervention des secours
chaud il a eu chaud larbitre d'un match
de championnat suisse poursuivi par la
mode des footballeurs agressive dans
joueurs son collègue yougoslave si lui
ne se laisse pas impressionner et
devient un roi du coup de boule ont-ils
donc perdu la boule jean pierre papin
qui embrasse le président en finale de
la cou cantona qui jette son maillot de
l'olympique de marseille où la mère d'un
bug sur noir anglais qui ne supporte pas
la défaite de son fils chang qui joue la
cuillère et ramasse lendl à la petite
cuillère sénat qui joue les kamikazes
avant de se faire hara kiri devant prost
lesage
de quoi mettre fignon chaos fignon le
perdant du duel de l'année pour huit
secondes huit secondes de trop pour
fignon une seconde de bonheur pour les
morts enfin l' instant de gloire pour
cet anonyme du 110 m haies y/y l'espace
de quelques secondes devient végal des
stars voilà c'est ce soir sur antenne 2
à 22h15 tout de suite les résultats du
tiercé quarté voilà voici le tiercé
10,16 trêve 2180 14.50 dans l'ordre de
100 sont douces sont dans le désordre le
quarté qui est un kart et samedi 16 13
14 21 1691 150 dans leur 961 france dans
un ordre différent la météo s'est tout
de suite avec laurent cabrol dernière
édition philippe gassot vers 23h30
aussitôt après les exploits sportifs et
les trophées d'antenne 2 et demain matin
les premiers journaux de la rédaction
sera représentée par isabelle bechler et
claire chazal bonne soirée à tous et à
demain 20h sur intel